could the oakland athletics be moving
right onto the las vegas strip while the
team has its sights set on a spot we'll
tell you more about it here at 11 i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftus
thanks for joining us the a's talking
about the tropicana for the site of a
future ballpark there's a lot to unpack
here we've got team coverage beginning
with sasha loftis who looked at the
traffic side of things sasha
denise and brian the idea of this is all
really exciting but we spoke with
drivers in this area tonight who say
they can't imagine the traffic
congestion getting any worse than it
already is
it's no secret the golden knights and
the raiders have made las vegas all
about sports
now the oakland a's could make their
move to nevada as cnbc reported
wednesday that the mlb team is
considering a bid on the tropicana site
for potential ballpark location it would
be great for the city
it could be really cool but it's also
smack dab in the middle of the already
congested las vegas strip las vegas
boulevard
could definitely
slow down on you drivers we spoke with
say they already see cars lining the
road and people packing sidewalks and
pedestrian bridges on foot alleviate the
traffic adrian packer of the nevada
department of transportation tells us
their options for change are limited
there's little we can do as far as
widening our roads because
as you know
the casinos go right up to the
roadways so if another sports venue were
to add even more crowds we could see
some gridlock in our future as for those
on the roads they're not looking forward
to any traffic headaches it's one way
you know but add that they'll do their
best to adapt with our ever changing
city
now something to note ndot says they are
soon starting work on the tropicana i-15
interchange that should alleviate some
of the congestion here on the south end
of the strip in the next few years that
is set to be complete in 2024